hello everyone it seems like only
yesterday at Magnus Carlsen and Sergey
Kerrigan were battling it out in New
York for the title of the world champion
and already we have a list of eight
names that will be the participants of
the candidates tournament in 2018 the
2018 candidates tournament will be held
in Germany in Berlin in March and the
players that will be participating our
Sergey Kerrigan who immediately had the
invitation since he was the Challenger
in the previous championship we have
eleven Ariane and ting Liron who wonder
wonder invitation by placing number one
in one of the two top spots in the world
cup then we have mama D ro and Greece
choke who won their invitation by
claiming best players in the Grand Prix
series organized by fee day then we have
Wesley so and Fabiano Caruana who were
invited due to their rating well due to
their average rating during the entire
2017 and we have the wild-card who was
given to Vladimir Kramnik and a lot of
people are saying that although Kramnik
is an amazing player I you know nobody
disagrees with that but a lot of people
are thinking that maybe maybe Maxime
Barcia holograph should have gotten the
wild card as the wild card is given by
the organizers by Aegon and the only the
only real criteria you have to fulfill
is that any time during the 2017 you
have to have a rating higher than 220
725 so I haven't really studied this
matter a lot you know so those of you
who have I'm very interested do you
agree with the decision that Kramnik got
the wild card or would you maybe prefer
that Maxime got to the wild card either
way we're gonna have a very interesting
candidate series and I'm very eager to
see who will be able if Levin can
continue his onslaught he's been doing
for the whole year now or well someone
else maybe maybe take the lead but I
decided to show a Maxine game and I
decided to show you a game it was played
in Norway chess in it was Magnus Carlsen
won the event and this game
Maxine holograph is playing against
onigiri with the black pieces and of
course we have a most interesting
opening the Sicilian as Maxine Marshall
Agra is known as a sicilian specialist
especially in the night off so let's see
the game Giri has the white pieces and
he plays efore c5 Knight to f3 d6 d4
seek after son d4 Knight captures on d4
and Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and a6
Maxine goes for the neither variation
Bishop to g5 e six we have four eight
six now Bishop to h4 and Queen to b6 a
three by Giri and Bishop to e7 probably
already everyone knows but just in case
someone doesn't you can't capture the
beauty pawn because Knight to a4 and
your queen is trapped so after a three
magazine goes for Bishop to e7
we have Bishop to f2 now threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries with the
night Queen to c7 getting the Queen out
of the way Queen to f3 Knight B to d7
and a queenside castle by giri b5 maxim
is now expanding on the Queen side is
ready to attack the castle king g4 Gary
does the same on the Kings side and the
immediate g5 by Maxine h4 by Gary and Ji
captures on f4 and this is a this is a
very unusual position as a get replaced
at Bishop to e2 you know he could have
done for g5 and what what we have after
g5 is something like Knight to e5 Queen
captures on f4 and after Knight g6 with
a temple on the Queen Queen to a 395
Queen f4 96 and a possible to draw by
repetition was here in the position and
it's it's very peculiar and Gary decided
not to go for this but okay instead
after G captures on a4 Bishop to e2 by
giri and rook the g8 now let's see me
stopping g5 rook D to G 1 again Giri is
preparing g5 and now d5 maxime expanded
and the Queen side and now he wants to
break up in the center even though his
King is still on e8 e character son b5
and we have
Knight to e5 although in this position
again g5 was a possibility but give it
decides not to go for it he captures on
d5
we have knight Knight to e5 would a
temple on the Queen Queen 2 H 3 and now
we capture some d5 and now Geary
transverses the rook from g1 to e1 as
the position I opened up Maxim's King is
still on e8 so Geary would definitely
enjoy a rock on an open file Maxime gets
rid of this by simply playing King to f8
and although it's quite an open position
Maxime does have a pretty open King and
f8 but the king is actually very safe
there as you'll see Knight to f5 by
Geary threatening the bishop and
threatening to capture the ah-6 pawn
maxine captures at Bishop characters on
a 5g captures on f5 and Bishop to c5 now
gear replace Queen to f1 capturing the
bishop doesn't really relieve white of
any problems as after Queen captures
again Maxime is threatening d4 d3 it
would be pretty much the same as what
happens in the game after Bishop to c5
Queen to f1 was played and now d4
kicking the night away from c3 we have
nights to be won by Geary and Knight to
e4 and this is a very very hard position
to play for Geary there are a lot of
moves are threatened here d3 is always a
possibility you have to calculate so we
have Bishop to f3 now give pins this
knight on e4 but Maxime doesn't mind
Maxime plays Knight captures on f2 and
what do you do here well Aguirre decides
to accept the challenge although
declining it doesn't really help white
in this position and get replaced Bishop
captures on a 8 and here Maxine has a
beautiful beautiful strike he plays
Knight e2 e3
with Czech and what do you do here well
giri played into d2 and this is in fact
the best move the knight unfortunately
can be captured if you play C captures
on v3 you get Bishop characters on a3
now opening up of this cover to check
from the Queen and after something like
tonight's the c3 this
doesn't help you Queen captures on c3
wins immediately for black so you can't
block with the night you have to play
something like King to d2 and now Bishop
to b4 check King EE - and now f3 and
whatever you do you're getting checked
checkmated if you play King characters
on f2 then Queen to g3 this is checkmate
and if you capture maybe the pawn on f3
then again Queen to g3 check in e2 and a
queen to e3 this is again checkmate so a
very hard position for giri indeed after
night e to d3 check giri played probably
i mean ok he played the strongest move
but it doesn't help king to d2 and now
maxine plays knife captures any one giri
captures the knight on f2 queen capture
sangee on f2 and now d3 opening up a
discovered attack from the bishop to the
queen on f2 and there is really nothing
for white to hope for here it's a
completely lost position Gary tries
Queen captures anyone but now comes
Bishop to e3 check and in this position
onigiri resigned the game as it doesn't
really matter what he does if you play
something like king came to d1 then of
course Queen captures and c2 is
checkmate if you play King captures on
d3 then Queen the c4 is checkmate and
lastly if you if you capture the Queen
and hope for the best then Queen
captures and c2 with check King G 1 and
F captures on e3 again you're getting
checkmated so nothing really nothing
really Fergie read to do in this
position after Bishop d3 check and give
resign the game and you know that that's
probably what he got for not going for
that g5 and draw by repetition but
nevertheless a wonderful game by a
machine wash air or a Grove at 28 move
brilliancy if I might say so you know
really really enjoy watching his games
in the Sicilian because you know he
really is an expert so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and once
again I am really interested what do you
think is is Vladimir Kramnik justified
decision by the organizers or maybe
maybe you would prefer
to see Maxine for sheer allograph being
given a chance chance for the title and
aside from that who do you think has the
most chances to win the candidates so
yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon